how often are you looking for scripts to
purchase constantly what's your process
where are you looking I'm looking right
now for a script for my next movie and
working on ideas at the same time we've
had some bumps in the road I tried to
option a book and we got very excited
about it and it turned out that the book
was entangled in another country even
though the rights had run out the other
country had tax credit for the film and
gave them advance funds which I didn't
know this but legally terminate any kind
of future purchase because the money is
already in play wow I never knew that
it's fascinating information because I
would never think that either you just
these are all things that I don't think
the writer of the book knew that either
yeah Wow
so so once you found out that that's
probably a no-go at least for now
what's a week ago okay the how do you
kind of get back on the horse and start
looking for some started immediately you
know a filmmaker typically doesn't have
just one project that he's interested in
doing in my case I have a pretty
important mandate I'm only looking to do
projects that are personally beneficial
to the world and I'm not talking about
pollution or something like that I'm
talking about a meaningful project that
would help people engage and and and see
things the filmmaking is so brilliant I
just saw a great movie I can mention it
called the insult and it is it's a
masterpiece why is it a masterpiece go
see the movie and you understand because
it talks about you know it didn't matter
that it was filmed in Lebanon what
mattered to me was it could have been
anywhere and whether you're talking
positive about politics or negative it
could have happened anywhere and it was
not a true story it was fiction but the
way it was filmed in the way it was
written really tells a great
story about tolerance and talks about
hatred and when when you see a film like
that and you walk out you you're you're
affected in a way almost Shakespearean
and that's the kind of films that I want
to make films that viscerally help you
understand the world more and maybe make
you more tolerant maybe make you more
perceptive and you know certainly
filmmaking is one of the best vehicles
other than speech and to me our book a
filmmaker you know really has an
opportunity to tell story and with the
the belief not in purposeful preaching
but the belief is you'll walk out and
you'll have a perspective you might
never have had